لمتابعه المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي الاساسيه لحماس وتم الضرب
الالاف من مخرب وكذلك في مخازنهم وسلاحهم
وانفاق لكن لا هناك ليس هناك حل يضمن
القضاء على جيوب المقاومه في كل مكان
والان بما ان ذلك يحدث فطبيعي
ان نتلقى يتم اطلاق النار علينا وهذا
طبيعي يجب على مواطنين ان لا تختلط عليهم
الامور في السابق كانت خطه حماس ان تطلق
مئات الصواريخ علينا بشكل يومي في كل
انحاء البلاد اما اليوم فينجح فقط في
اطلاق عشرات الصواريخ في نقاط محدده طبعا
انا لا استهتر بهذا وهذا امر خطير ولكننا
نقوم باستهدافه من خلال عمليات اقتحام
وقصف جوي لكن هذا سيستغرق وقتا ويمتد على
الاقل على الشهور القليله الماضيه
وبالتالي يجب ان يكون ذلك واضحا للجمهور
جنودنا يقاتلون ووجوهم الى غزه وظهورهم
تحمي بلداتنا وهم فكرنا بكلا الامرين هذا
هو الوضع ويجب ان تكون مستوى توقعات
المواطنين ملائمه مع ذلك ولكن بشكل عام
اود ان اقول بشكل واضح مهم ان تفهموا ذلك
في هذا المنتدى حماس تخدو اكثر ضعفا لانها
تفتقد الامدادات
و القوى البشريه وتفتقد ايضا الى القدرات
التي تدير فيها عملياتها ولا يمكن وهي
فقدت زمام الامور فقدت على زمام الامور
ونحن نقوم باضعاف وفي نفس الوقت نحن نصبح
اقوى نحن نحصل على الامدادات العسكريه
من واحيانا من الولايات المتحده ومصادر
اخرى فنقوم برص صفوفنا واعاده
التنظيم تجهيزاتنا العسكريه وكذلك ترتيب
الميزانيه وبالتالي ففي الجانب المادي
وليس في الجانب النفسي اتكلم عن الجانب
المادي فنحن نصبح اقوى الجيش يصبح اقوى
اما حماس فتصبح اضعف وفي النها هذا سيؤدي
الى نقطه فيها تنكسر
حماس وبالتالي فحماس لا تلعب الا على
الحبل الوحيد الذ ظل لها وهو العامل
النفسي والتلاعب بعواطف المواطنين عائلات
الاسرى يهددون وينشرون مقاطع فيديو
يتلاعبون بنفسيه الناس من اجل ان يسببوا
انقساما في المجتمع وبالتالي و فما هو
مطلوب هنا هو عناصره بسيطه
وواضحه ان نقضي على حماس
وان نفعل كل ما هو مطلوب ونعيد المختطفين
ونحافظ على وحدتنا اذا حافظنا على هذه
العناصر الثلاثه فنحن منتصرون بلا
شك واود هنا ان اتكلم عن قضيه الشمال بشكل
مبدئي
نحن ركزنا نقاشاتنا هنا على تطور خطير وهو
تطور يمكن ان ننزلق فيه الى حرب في الشمال
وما هو الوضع الاقليمي
الذي
وما يتعلق بدعم مواطنينا وخطوط امدادنا
وهنا تكلمنا عن ذلك
بالتفصيل واود ان اقول مجددا نحن نرغب بان
نكون في وضع لا نصل فيه الى حرب في الشمال
ولكن نكون قادرين على ان نعيد مواطنين
ليعيشوا بامان واذا لم يحصل ذلك اذا لم
نقدر على اعاده مواطننا بطرق دبلوماسيه
واتفاقيات فنحن سنضطر ان نخلق الظروف
الامنيه التي تتيح عودتهم لا اتكلم
عن جدول زمني او عن
اماكن لكن منذ اقامه هذا المنتدى في
السلطات المحليه اعتقد انكم تبلون بلاء
حسنا في
تجهيز ولكن كما هو الحال في ادارتنا
للامور في الجنوب فانتم راس حربه يجب ان
يكون وراءه جسم اكبر وهو حكومه اسرائيل
وبالتالي انا ساطرح هذا الامر لاتخاذ قرار
ف في الحكومه وانا واثق ان الحكومه سوف
تنضم
الينا وتقود الحل من خلال توفير
الموارد ونحن نشق الطريق ونعطي الخيارات
وفي اللحظه التي تلقي الحكومه بثقلها على
هذا ستكون هي الاداه التي
ستنفذ هذا المشروع وتعمل عليه واعتقد ان
هذه الطريقه
الصحيحه فالطريقه هي اداره
اقامه اداره شبيهه بالاداره في
الجنوب علينا ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
احتمال تدهور الامر في الشمال حتى لو
اردنا ضد ذلك هناك عدو يستهدفنا من اليوم
الاول دون ان نكون قد فعلنا اي شيء يستفزه
وبالتالي فيبدو ان هذه المسيره معناها ان
احتمال تدهر الامور وارد جدا واذا حصل ذلك
فنحن س
سوف يدفعون ثمنا باهضا على ذلك حزب الله
ولبنان ولكن ايضا ستكون عندنا اضرار
وبالتالي يجب ان نكون
جاهزين